اكتمل المربع الذهبي اربع فرق تتنافس على
الكاس
واربعه حراس يتنافسون على القفاز الذهبي
كافضل حراس في البطوله العديد من حراس
المرمى في البطوله لميعه الكرواتي دومينيك
لباكوفيتش مثلا اصبح بطلا في بلاده بعد
تصده لركلات ترجيحيه يابانيه و ركله
برازيليه لكن بخلاف تالق الحراس ظهر ضعف
المسددين البعض يرجحنا الضغط النفسي عامل
اساسي وانا ركلات الجزاء اصبحت كابوسا
للاعبين لويس انريكي مدرب المنتخب
الاسباني مثلا قال ان لاعبين تدربوا على
الف ركله جزاء والنتيجه ان نفس اللاعبين
اهدروا ثلاث ركلات امام المغرب العملاق
تحديدا تصدى لركلتين منها
[موسيقى]
اللاعب
الكره
عنده برود عند نوع من الصبر شوف الزاويه
صح
اكثر
[موسيقى]
الكره
ممكن
يحضر فقط
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان المشكله هو مشكل نفسي بالدرجه
الاولى طريقه تعامل اللاعبين مع الضغوط
هناك ضغوط كبيره جدا على اللاعبين في عالم
كره القدم الحديث ربما في السنوات الماضيه
في العشريات الماضيه في الاجيال الماضيه
كره القدم كانت تعتمد اكثر على المتعه
يعني لا وجود تكتيكيه كبيره على اللاعبين
لا وجود لقيود اعلاميه كبيره على اللاعبين
جماهيريه ايضا الان كبرت اموال كره القدم
ومعها كبرت الضغوط وكبر الطموح وهمم
والجماهير دائما تطالب اللاعبين
مردود اكبر لذلك اعتقد ان التعامل
اللاعبين مع ركلات الجزاء والتعامل
اللاعبين مع هذه الضغوط هو ما ادى الى
تضيع الكثير من ركلات الجزاء شاهدنا كيف
تضيع اليونان ميسي وهو اعظم لاعب في همم
كره القدم في العالم حاليا ركلته جزاء في
هذا المونديال شاهدنا الكثير من اللاعبين
الكبار يضيعون ركلات الجزاء
المقابل نشاهد لاعبين مغمورين يسجلون
ركلات الجزاء هذا هو الفرق الفرق في
التعامل مع الضغوط النفسيه
لركله الجزاء ولكل فريق تميز خاص بها
الاحيان كيف يقدم مدرب حراس المرمى ورقه
مثل ما فعل عصام الحضري في همم كاس
افريقيا الماضيه حين قدم ورقه الى حارس
مرمى المنتخب المصري في ركلات الجزاء في
مباراه من المباريات همم همم الورقه مكتوب
عليها كل لاعب سيسدد الى اي ناحيه سيسدد
وهذا بالاعتماد على الاحصائيات عصام
الحضري بعدها صراحه مؤكدا انه درس جميع
لاعبي همم المنتخب درس جميع المسددين
المسددين ركلات الجزاء وفي اخر المطاف
نجحت الخطه والمنتخب المصري فاز بفضل تصدي
الحارس لهذه الركلات لذلك في كره القدم
الحديثه همم يعتمد المدربون واللاعبون
ايضا على الاحصائيات الحارس همم دائما ما
يدرس طريقه تسديد اللاعبين المنافسين
تقريبا اللاعبون المسددين لركلات الجزاء
معروفون سلفا لذلك الحارس يقوم بدراسه كل
لاعب على حدا واي الجهتين يسدد همم لها
هذا الحارس